but first good evening and welcome to
tucker carlson tonight on last night's
show we interviewed a US senator called
Mike Braun Braun as a Republican who
represents the very Republican state of
Indiana Braun ran for office two years
ago as a conservative but he has not
governed like one as the mob burned
cities and shot police officers Mike
Braun used his power in the US Senate to
punish local police cops where the real
problem Braun decided so he sponsored
legislation to make it easier for
left-wing activist groups to sue and
bankrupt individual police officers and
then Mike Braun endorsed black lives
matter do you support the the black
lives matter movement I support that
movement because it's addressing and
equity that has not been solved you know
from a grassroots level it's hard to
imagine that many of Mike Brown's voters
agree with any of that black lives
matter has said it wants to eliminate
police departments dismantle the nuclear
family and install socialism in the
United States even in the highly
revolutionary year of 2020 those don't
seem like winning positions in the state
of Indiana
so we asked Mike Braun to explain how
that works exactly and it didn't go well
we're not gonna play you the tape it
feels like piling on to do that what was
some it up this way at one point in the
interview Mike Braun explained that he
was pushing left-wing legislation
because he was afraid of being
criticized by Chuck Schumer if he didn't
the whole thing went like that it was
remarkable almost beyond belief really
again we're not trying to be mean here
cruelty is easy to easy especially with
politicians the closer you get to them
the easier you realize it is and by the
way Mike Braun doesn't seem like a bad
person if you live next door to him
you'd probably like him Braun's just
weak and he doesn't really believe in
anything he's definitely not alone in
that an awful lot of Republican
officeholders
look very much like Mike Braun right now
probably most of them that's a problem
in a moment like this it is a severe and
dangerous problem here's why Republicans
at all levels could lose this fall if
they do there will be profound
consequences for you people who support
Donald Trump will be punished there's
absolutely no question about that
there's never been an American political
party as radical and is angry as the
Democrats are now imagine them with
unlimited power and that's what they
plan to get in their first year
Democrats will give voting rights to
every illegal alien in this country and
then encourage many others to join them
from abroad at a minimum that means more
than 20 million new democratic voters
overnight no Republican will win
nationally again we will have one-party
rule but Democrats don't plan to stop
there in Congress they will abolish the
filibuster that means they'll be able to
do whatever they want to do with just a
simple majority which they will have
they plan to pack the Senate by making
the District of Columbia a state giving
statehood to DC is unconstitutional
clearly but they're not worried about
that
they plan to pack the Supreme Court -
they've said so
so what will Democrats do with all of
this untrammeled power it's pretty easy
to imagine we won't go into details
right now we don't want to wreck your
night but look around you've got a
pretty good idea of what's coming the
point is and it could not be clearer non
Democrats in America are in peril we're
gonna need someone with power willing to
come to our defense and that's where
people like Mike Braun come in that was
the point of last night's interview not
to humiliate a specific senator but to
remind the Republican Party that it is
our only shield yes the Republican Party
flawed and infuriating though it often
is the fact remains the GOP is the only
institution still open to the rest of us
to Americans who want to live as they
did just 15 years ago quietly
productively without being harassed and
harangues
by self-righteous lunatics who mean them
harm and they do if you want to be left
alone to do your job and raise your
family in this country you will need a
protector that protector must be the
Republican Party there are no other
options but it must be a very different
kind of Republican Party keep in mind
we're getting a new Republican Party no
matter what happens even now vultures
wait just offstage to swoop
and claim the GOP for themselves once
Donald Trump is gone former Governor
nikki Haley tops that list but there are
many others on it the moment Trump
leaves they will attack him they'll tell
you that Republicans lost power because
they were mean and intolerant just like
Donald Trump and if you listen carefully
you can hear them say that even now it's
a lie
Republicans are failing for a much more
obvious reason a more fundamental reason
they're failing because they haven't
done much that is worth doing
they haven't tried very hard to improve
your life when the crisis came they fled
they did nothing to defend you they did
nothing to defend the country they were
paralyzed their so-called principles
turned out to be bumper stickers they
wrote 40 years ago they had no clue what
to do so from this day forward it's very
simple we're going to have to tell them
what to do and that will work no matter
what they may believe privately
politicians respond to organized groups
of voters they want to win above all so
they head to where the votes are going
forward Republican voters should demand
three things from their candidates and
if they don't provide them don't vote
for them here they are first is vigorous
defense of total equality under the law
we are equal because we are citizens
every American has precisely the same
rights as every other American period
that is the promise of America it's why
millions of people move here for a long
time we knew that no one questioned it
it was obvious but it no longer is
obvious and there are many who are
working in the opposite direction
Republicans must counterbalance this
they must work as hard as they can to
make America fair again wealth
appearance ancestry can play no role
whatsoever in the eyes of the law that
means that criminals like Jeffrey
Epstein must go to jail the first time
they're caught molesting children it
means your children must have precisely
the same chances of getting into college
or getting a job as anyone else's
children it means fighting to make this
a colorblind meritocracy a colorblind
meritocracy
say it again the alternative to that is
disaster slavery and Jim Crow were
immoral precisely because they punished
people for how they were born any system
that punishes people for how they were
born is immoral always Republicans must
say that loudly don't get caught in
pointless debates about whether or not
this is a racist country clearly it
isn't prove it by making it less racist
by making it a colorblind meritocracy
that's our promise second Republicans
must defend our freedom of speech we are
not a free society without that this is
not simply a debate about the First
Amendment and its limits it's bigger
than that and more important if you
can't articulate something if you're not
allowed you can't think it and that's
precisely why authoritarians try to
control language they're trying to
control your mind
Republicans should lead the fight
against this without shame Americans
have the absolute right to tell the
truth this is not negotiable nor by the
way is it a theoretical concern of
interest only two intellectuals
everything depends on it if you can't
think freely you can't solve problems
try to build a hydro plant or fly a
commercial airplane if certain
categories of thought are off-limits to
you it doesn't work the power grid
collapses planes crash society degrades
no speech means no science no art no
civilization most of us were taught that
this debate was settled conclusively
during the Enlightenment hundreds of
years ago in reason vanquished dogma but
it wasn't settled the forces of
superstition remain they are stronger
than ever in fact they are growing in
strength the Republican Party must fight
them or it's not a party worth having
and finally we must never forget that in
the end the Republican Party exists to
serve the interests of normal people
ordinary people middle-class families
are the core of this country they are
hope for the future our only hope and
yet both parties have shamelessly
abandoned them middle-class families
have no national spokesman they have no
lobby in Washington Republicans pretend
to be their champion you know by now
that they are not instead of improving
the lives of their vote
the party feeds them a steady diet of
mindless symbolic victories partisan
junk food designed to make them feel
full even as they waste away who cares
how many Benghazi hearings we have we're
supposed to care why should we how did
Peter Struck's text messages become more
important than saving American jobs from
foreign nationals who are taking them it
is lunacy we fall for it every time and
to the extent this show has participated
in it
we apologize with deepest sincerity
because meanwhile as we're talking about
things that don't matter
life for the dwindling American middle
class has become steadily worse suddenly
there are junkies living in your Park
your nephew just died of a fentanyl
overdose and saddest of all and who
hasn't thought this you've realized that
your children will never be as
successful as you are the American Dream
died with your generation as all of this
happened
Democrats laughed because it served
their interests Republicans basically
ignored it and that cannot continue the
only political movements that endure are
the ones that make their voters stronger
so how does this change can Republican
officeholders change their party yes
they can we just have to make them these
are not by and large evil people Mike
Braun is not an evil person despite the
way they talk they're not secretly
working for the other side most of them
are just empty sad people and politics
is the way they fill the yawning void
inside where a personal life should be
their pleasers they're searching for the
approval of strangers our job is to give
them clear instructions about what we
want we do that by voting and by making
noise they will not lead us we know that
now they've refused to we have to lead
and when we do they will follow